looking back what is the most beautiful
or surprising idea in deep learning or
AI in general that you've come across
you've seen this field explode
and grow in interesting ways just what
what cool ideas like like we made you
sit back and go hmm small big or small
well the one that I've been thinking
about recently the most probably is the
the Transformer architecture
um so basically uh neural networks have
a lot of architectures that were trendy
have come and gone for different sensory
modalities like for Vision Audio text
you would process them with different
looking neural nuts and recently we've
seen these convergence towards one
architecture the Transformer and you can
feed it video or you can feed it you
know images or speech or text and it
just gobbles it up and it's kind of like
a bit of a general purpose uh computer
that is also trainable and very
efficient to run on our Hardware
and so this paper came out in 2016 I
want to say
um attention is all you need attention
is all you need you criticize the paper
title in retrospect that it wasn't
um it didn't foresee the bigness of the
impact yeah that it was going to have
yeah I'm not sure if the authors were
aware of the impact that that paper
would go on to have probably they
weren't but I think they were aware of
some of the motivations and design
decisions behind the Transformer and
they chose not to I think uh expand on
it in that way in a paper and so I think
they had an idea that there was more
um than just the surface of just like oh
we're just doing translation and here's
a better architecture you're not just
doing translation this is like a really
cool differentiable optimizable
efficient computer that you've proposed
and maybe they didn't have all of that
foresight but I think is really
interesting isn't it funny sorry to
interrupt that title is memeable that
they went for such a profound idea they
went with the I don't think anyone used
that kind of title before right
protection is all you need yeah it's
like a meme or something basically it's
not funny that one like uh maybe if it
was a more serious title it wouldn't
have the impact honestly I yeah there is
an element of me that honestly agrees
with you and prefers it this way yes
if it was two grand it would over
promise and then under deliver
potentially so you want to just uh meme
your way to greatness
that should be a t-shirt so you you
tweeted the Transformers the Magnificent
neural network architecture because it
is a general purpose differentiable
computer it is simultaneously expressive
in the forward pass optimizable via back
propagation gradient descent and
efficient High parallelism compute graph
can you discuss some of those details
expressive optimizable efficient
yeah from memory or or in general
whatever comes to your heart you want to
have a general purpose computer that you
can train on arbitrary problems uh like
say the task of next word prediction or
detecting if there's a cat in the image
or something like that and you want to
train this computer so you want to set
its its weights and I think there's a
number of design criteria that sort of
overlap in the Transformer
simultaneously that made it very
successful and I think the authors were
kind of uh deliberately trying to make
this really uh powerful architecture and
um so in a basically it's very powerful
in the forward pass because it's able to
express
um very uh General computation as a sort
of something that looks like message
passing you have nodes and they all
store vectors and these nodes get to
basically look at each other and it's
each other's vectors and they get to
communicate and basically notes get to
broadcast hey I'm looking for certain
things and then other nodes get to
broadcast hey these are the things I
have those are the keys and the values
so it's not just the tension yeah
exactly Transformer is much more than
just the attention component it's got
many pieces architectural that went into
it the residual connection of the way
it's arranged there's a multi-layer
perceptron in there the way it's stacked
and so on
um but basically there's a message
passing scheme where nodes get to look
at each other decide what's interesting
and then update each other and uh so I
think the um when you get to the details
of it I think it's a very expressive
function uh so it can express lots of
different types of algorithms and
forward paths not only that but the way
it's designed with the residual
connections layer normalizations the
soft Max attention and everything it's
also optimizable this is a really big
deal because there's lots of computers
that are powerful that you can't
optimize or they're not easy to optimize
using the techniques that we have which
is back propagation and gradient and
send these are first order methods very
simple optimizers really and so um you
also need it to be optimizable
um and then lastly you want it to run
efficiently in the hardware our Hardware
is a massive throughput machine like
gpus they prefer lots of parallelism so
you don't want to do lots of sequential
operations you want to do a lot of
operations serially and the Transformer
is designed with that in mind as well
and so it's designed for our hardware
and it's designed to both be very
expressive in a forward pass but also
very optimizable in the backward pass
and you said that uh the residual
connections support a kind of ability to
learn short algorithms fast them first
and then gradually extend them longer
during training yeah what's what's the
idea of learning short algorithms right
think of it as a so basically a
Transformer is a series of uh blocks
right and these blocks have attention
and a little multi-layer perceptron and
so you you go off into a block and you
come back to this residual pathway and
then you go off and you come back and
then you have a number of layers
arranged sequentially and so the way to
look at it I think is because of the
residual pathway in the backward path
the gradients uh sort of flow along it
uninterrupted because addition
distributes the gradient equally to all
of its branches so the gradient from the
supervision at the top uh just floats
directly to the first layer and the all
these residual connections are arranged
so that in the beginning during
initialization they contribute nothing
to the residual pathway
um so what it kind of looks like is
imagine the Transformer is kind of like
a uh python function like a death and um
you get to do various kinds of like
lines of code so you have a hundred
layers deep uh Transformer typically
they would be much shorter say 20. so
you have 20 lines of code then you can
do something in them and so think of
during the optimization basically what
it looks like is first you optimize the
first line of code and then the second
line of code can kick in and the third
line of code can and I kind of feel like
because of the residual pathway and the
Dynamics of the optimization uh you can
sort of learn a very short algorithm
that gets the approximate tensor but
then the other layers can sort of kick
in and start to create a contribution
and at the end of it you're you're
optimizing over an algorithm that is uh
20 lines of code
except these lines of code are very
complex because it's an entire block of
a transformer you can do a lot in there
what's really interesting is that this
Transformer architecture actually has
been a remarkably resilient basically
the Transformer that came out in 2016 is
the Transformer you would use today
except you reshuffle some of the layer
norms the player normalizations have
been reshuffled to a pre-norm
formulation and so it's been remarkably
stable but there's a lot of bells and
whistles that people have attached to it
and try to uh improve it I do think that
basically it's a it's a big step in
simultaneously optimizing for lots of
properties of a desirable neural network
architecture and I think people have
been trying to change it but it's proven
remarkably resilient but I do think that
there should be even better
architectures potentially but it's uh
your you admire the resilience here yeah
there's something profound about this
architecture that at least so maybe we
can everything could be turned into a
uh into a problem that Transformers can
solve currently definitely looks like
the Transformers taking over Ai and you
can feed basically arbitrary problems
into it and it's a general
differentiable computer and it's
extremely powerful and uh this
convergence in AI has been really
interesting to watch uh for me
personally what else do you think could
be discovered here about Transformers
like a surprising thing or or is it a
stable
um
we're in a stable place is there
something interesting we might discover
about Transformers like aha moments
maybe has to do with memory uh maybe
knowledge representation that kind of
stuff
definitely the Zeitgeist today is just
pushing like basically right now there's
that guys is do not touch the
Transformer touch everything else yes so
people are scaling up the data sets
making them much much bigger they're
working on the evaluation making the
evaluation much much bigger and uh
um they're basically keeping the
architecture unchanged and that's how
we've um that's the last five years of
progress in AI kind of